joining us on the line is robert haley
he is the chief pollster at the
trafalgar group he gained media
attention in 2016 he was one of the few
pollsters to accurately predict
the election of president trump he now
suggests that president trump may in
fact have the upper hand going into
election day robert thanks so much for
joining the show i really appreciate it
oh it's great to be here so let's talk
about
uh why trafalgar seems to be taking the
the sort of
counter-intuitive stance that trump has
the advantage
uh in the election tomorrow most of the
available polling averages suggest that
trump
has a very slim chance of winning in the
electoral college no chance of winning
the national
popular vote the the polling averages
have
a lot of the swing states's margin of
error arizona florida north carolina
margin of error
the blue wall states of michigan
wisconsin and pennsylvania they've got
those pulled
out anywhere from a biden seven point
lead to a biden three-point lead in in
places like pennsylvania
where do you have these various states
rated uh we have florida
arizona and north carolina all as winds
are better than two percent we have
michigan
at a wind of about uh two percent uh
pennsylvania to win over on one percent
wisconsin i think we have
trump down by one percent and i think
he's down by two percent
in minnesota however uh
in minnesota we have uh uh kanye getting
3.3 we think some of that will fade away
without kanye trump is winning minnesota
uh and nevada i believe we had
a trump down by two and a half percent
okay so so looking at those differences
in poll statistics uh is that just a
difference
in in how the modeling is done and how
you're weighting particular votes and
and what is the vote that people are
are missing is it the rural white vote
is it sort of a silent generalized trump
vote well what exactly is everybody else
missing if you guys are right
uh it's it's not actually in in the the
waiting or modeling it's it's more in
the in the construction
how we do our surveys one we really work
very hard to minimize the social
desirability
bias which is the tendency of people to
give an answer that's
you know makes them look best in the
eyes of the person asking the question
so a lot of these are media polls that
rely on live callers which is the
absolute worst way to poll someone like
trump because people are hesitant to
admit they're voting for him
and even when you do things that aren't
live it
you have to you have to fight that
because there's people
conservatives and michael moore even
said this best the conservatives are
a little iffy about kind of revealing
that for trump
on the phone or in any way so you've got
to really work to
to minimize that effect in every way
that you can
uh we also include in our samples people
that uh
are not necessarily most people consider
likely voters we look to people that we
think
are going to be first-time voters or
first-time at a long-time voters
we did the same thing in 2016 and we saw
who the new people were who showed up in
the primaries
uh and then we built a model for the
fall that said hey let's
assume these people that meet these same
you know that we came up with like 57
characteristics and people that met like
12 or more of them we put as top
potential people who would participate
in the election
uh and we're doing the same thing this
year there's a lot of low propensity
voters we think that are definitely
going to vote in this thing
and so we've kind of modeled out what
they look like and
they represent part of our sample we
also don't believe in
so are you mayors oh yeah
i'm sorry are you surprised by the
amount of uh early voting that we've
seen i mean the voter turnout is
extraordinary this year we already are
above it 100 of 2016 in places like
texas
uh florida is approaching 100 uh is that
difficult to model for or is the model
basically the same
well what you what you do is measure it
like for example we've discovered that
in pennsylvania
and michigan um those who voted by mail
early
or disproportionately by those who voted
in person early
trump has the edge and those who voted
on election day trump has the edge
so um you've got to keep track of how
people are voting
and um and you've seen some of these
conservative numbers that are coming out
numbers that indicate that trump is
doing a little better than people
thought
in some of the early voting and
republicans waited a little later to
send their ballots back
but i think
a large turnout i believe overall
is very good for trump because the
people who really really hate trump
have been voting consistently since uh
they turned out everywhere and so i
think that the
the fact that trump seems to be able to
awaken people
that nobody's counting on voting and
bring them in i mean some of the
statistics from his rallies are very
impressive
we've always known he had large democrat
support we've argued for quite some time
that
since 2016 that trump did better among
democrats and independents and
minorities than people know
and he did a little worse among some of
the republican and republican
establishment that people will know so
we're not shocked at all to see
a large amount of democrats that are for
trump
we're speaking with robert k haley he's
chief polster at trafalgar group
uh so where did you you got some of the
swing states right in uh in 2016 in a
way nobody else did um
what was your overall record in 2016. so
did you get everything right in 2016 or
was it just particular
everybody else got it wrong you got
right we got three states wrong
of the all 15 47 which was better than
everyone else
and we got lucky in the three states we
got wrong
still electoral equal 306 to 232 which
we also predicted
but the uh the three states equaled um
they were
they were actually wisconsin they were
all states we didn't poll
but we used other people's polling on
the averages to
demonstrate we didn't we
couldn't really afford to pull them all
ourselves but wisconsin
is equal in electoral votes to nevada
plus new hampshire
so we got nevada in new hampshire for
trump and wisconsin for
uh clinton and it worked out perfectly
but yeah we only got
of those we got all the even the little
congressional districts right
we missed three out of um 50.
so in terms of how you're identifying
the the sort of shy trump vote or people
who are
um trying to you know avoid social
desirability uh
issues so what kind of questions do you
ask people to try to eliminate the
social desirability bias well and four
years ago we asked the neighbor question
as a projection device so people can
kind of say what
you assign this position
without kind of you know taking it on
themselves it was that it was their
position
but uh it's like i said it's a
projection device
uh well we would have seen is since we
told everybody that in the media that
all these different groups are copying
that
so we have all kinds of new techniques
this year and we are not sharing these
okay so you know looking at uh at
election night so you think that trump
is actually going to win a fairly broad
victory because you've got trump
up in florida you've got him up in
arizona and north carolina and then you
say you have him up
right now in basically all of the
north all of the midwest swing states
including minnesota
if you're right about kanye west so um
is everybody else gonna have to learn to
code if you're right wisconsin
we and we think you will probably come
in second in minnesota as well
uh the only states that right now we're
still looking around mid-270s
because i have this belief about
pennsylvania that if trump doesn't win
it by at least four points
he'll never get that victory they've got
some systematic voter fraud
not limited to their supreme court
allowing
ballots without postmark to be counted
so i think trump
even though we have him up by one he has
to win pennsylvania by
four or more to actually get those votes
and get that fair victory
so all right so let's let's talk about
that for a second so
you've talked about uh you know
pennsylvania voter fraud so pennsylvania
obviously
is going to be counting votes beyond the
election uh the rules in pennsylvania
allow for the the votes to be counted
maybe maybe not with or without a
postmark
uh so it could be that people are voting
after the actual election day
believing that uh a late wave for biden
will put him over the top
over there i'm pretty skeptical
generally of both claims of voter
suppression by the left and claims of
voter fraud on the right what sort of
evidence do we have
that there's going to be widespread
voter fraud that republicans should be
worried about
well first of all there's there are
numerous uh
philadelphia at their literally every
time i get a call from one of these
philadelphia reporters
i send them send an email with like 15
articles
of all the voter fraud and voter
convictions and everything else that
happened in the city of philadelphia
and i mean simply the supreme court
ruling dominated by democrats on the
state supreme court allowing votes to
come in without a postmark
i mean that's the door right there i
mean you can dismiss everything else
that ruling in and of itself lets
somebody figure out how many votes they
need
flood them in with no fear of a postmark
throwing them out
that is there that is not
a legit way to vote i mean you
postmarked this it's a simple thing if
you can't get the postmark you get it
there in time
now presumably if that actually happens
in a place like pennsylvania that will
be elevated to the supreme court again
so the supreme court sort of punted
that question down the road uh they
didn't say that they wouldn't accept the
case again
alito and uh kavanaugh and others on the
supreme court suggested that
if it comes down to pennsylvania and it
is that close that this may get elevated
to the supreme court again asking
questions about whether in fact
non-postmark ballots can be counted
which shows you why the supreme court
should have said this
in advance as opposed to waiting on as
opposed to waiting on
all of it so you know looking at the the
impact
of uh of kovid on all of this what kind
of turnout do you expect to see on
election day because there's a lot of
talk about how everybody
is the early voting in other words
drawing generally from people who are
going to vote
on election day or are we really seeing
this vast wave of new turnout
that wildly exceeds what anybody was
expecting i still think there's going to
be i mean
why do we exceed what people are
expecting in the total vote when it's
done yes
wildly exceeding what people expect on
election day as compared to normal
election days no
i think that that when it's all said and
done
the turnout on election day will be
sufficient that it
along with the early and absentee
mail-in turnout
will vastly exceed it and yeah i
i think that the people who are worried
about coba they voted and they voted
absentee
uh but you know we have uh we
we poll the kobe question all the time
and there's a very very small
segment of the population that is
willing to let kova dominate their life
anymore
uh the vast majority 60 plus percent of
the people are like hey
i wear the mask wash the hands you know
social distance
but you got to get back to life and uh
so i think that this issue of biden
won't rule out shutdowns and trump will
has really kind of shifted this race a
little bit we find
young people who tell us they don't like
the president
but they're going to vote for him
because they're sick of lockdowns
and nobody actually believes they work
uh that they believe that the
the socialistic the mass and uh
everything that's being done now is
just as effective as that is so there's
a real sense of getting back to life
and not ruling the economy and you're
seeing it from hourly workers
uh in nevada you're seeing it from moms
who want their kids back in school
i think it's become kind of the defining
issue in this campa
if that's the way people vote it won't
even be close on election day
so what what do you think um is going to
happen in the senate races obviously a
lot of very close senate races we've
seen
uh the republicans on sort of knife's
edge in terms of their majority joni
ernst has popped out to a lead
in iowa which is sort of unexpected tom
tillis and cal cunningham running a very
competitive race
in north carolina obviously both georgia
senate races right now
are within margin of error uh so
where do you think the senate ends up
well i don't buy most of that polling i
said joni erst was never in trouble to
begin with
um so that i didn't buy into that at all
um
i also don't believe that either one of
the georgia senate races
is in jeopardy uh i think that more than
likely you'll see a
a nice runoff happening on the uh on the
special election
and uh quite possibly uh you'll see
purdue elected with
reelected without a runoff um in the
other georgia race uh i think that uh
tillis is going to be victorious north
carolina is moving
uh that direction you know i i look up
there in maine and i just maine is
different
uh maine's you know the other senator's
an independent
you've got collins who kind of you know
voted for kavanaugh and against barrett
i mean that's kind of middle of the road
stuff in maine that it's not
that strange uh their rank choice voting
thing though it gives me some
calls on that one if this is the first
time testing all that out
and i don't know that i think there's a
wealthy gentleman running in there
don't know whether his votes end up at
their second choice being for
uh collins uh you know i think
when you look into colorado i think
that's going to be very tough for
gardner unless there's a trump wave of
three or four percent
i think if trump would have come within
two percent gardner can win that race
uh mcsally is totally dependent upon the
level of the trump victory
uh in arizona uh if he can win it by
three or four i think she
he pulls her up too i think john james
does win the senate race and defeat uh
peters and uh and and alabama i think
that's a
that's an easy win so i would say the
republicans
pick up one or lose one but i don't
think the majority is that much in
question
i'm robert k haley chief pollster at
trafalgar group
those are uh those are definitely bold
predictions and we'll see how they play
out tomorrow
i really appreciate your time absolutely
it's great to be on a show like this
thank you
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content